es sind die männer vor denen die welt
sich fürchtet die taliban sind zurück
eine neue generation alte ideale
wenn die islamische regierung errichtet
ist dann werden die taliban so gott will
herrschen wie vorherige regierungen in
der geschichte bilder die erinnerungen
wecken und angst machen
amerika zieht ab und beendet seinen
längsten krieg auch über den
stützpunkten der bundeswehr lädt jetzt
die afghanische flagge
wir treffen menschen die sich im stich
gelassen fühlen und uns ihre geschichten
erzählen so viele tote so viel schmerz
und die frage war es das wert für
afghanistans frauen steht viel auf dem
spiel viele beeindrucken die welt jetzt
mit ihrem mut und ihrer entschlossenheit
ich werde nie aufgeben ich werde meine
ziele verfolgen
unterwegs in einem land das auch für uns
immer gefährlicher wird
wohin steuert afghanistan chaos und
krieg oder gibt es noch hoffnung auf
frieden
wir sind in der provinz ghazni 200
kilometer von kabul entfernt
die taliban haben ein polizeiauto
erbeutet umringt von neugierigen dorf
jungen feuern sie auf die felder
niemand hält sie auf wie ihr seht
regieren die taliban jetzt alle
distrikte in der zukunft planen wir eine
islamische regierung zu errichten an der
sich jeder beteiligen kann und seine
rechte bekommt man zur afghanin formiert
per walkie talkie die kämpfer dass er
mit einem kamerateam vorbeikommt im auto
spielt seine lieblingsmusik
[Musik]
der mann der seine schwarze sonnenbrille
selten absetzt ist sprecher der taliban
in der provinz ghazni er führt uns durch
einen militärstützpunkt in dem bis vor
kurzem noch afghanische soldaten waren
vor vier monaten haben wir schon einmal
in der provinz gedreht jetzt begleiten
wir die taliban wieder drei tage lang
auch sajed more money ist zuständig
dafür ihre botschaften zu verbreiten
sie wollen der welt zeigen wie stark die
taliban wieder sind um einen blick auf
die umgebung zu bekommen klettern sie
auf die außenmauer des camps schon 2003
hat sich mama die den taliban
angeschlossen einige jahre hat er im
iran gelebt während ihre politischen
führer mit der regierung verhandeln
töten sie afghanische soldaten
die einsicht zu ergeben wenn sie nicht
aufgeben werden wir weiter kämpfen
sie werden getötet oder inhaftiert 35
jahre alt sein sagt sayed mohammadi
genau weiß er es nicht sein leben hat er
in den dienst der taliban gestellt wir
haben dafür gekämpft eine islamische
regierung zu errichten wenn die
islamische regierung errichtet ist dann
werden die taliban so gott will
herrschen die vorherige regierungen in
der geschichte
die meisten taliban stammen aus dieser
provinz sie kennen sich hier aus das ist
einer der gründe warum es ihnen gelingt
immer mehr distrikte zu erobern
wir fahren durch kultur eines der dörfer
des distriktes walkers seitdem die
taliban die macht übernommen haben sind
die frauen von den straßen verschwunden
selbst über die felder gehen sie nur in
burkas gehüllt untertanen eines schatten
regimes die jungen spielen mit den
lehrern munitions hülsen die die kämpfer
überall hinterlassen haben
[Musik]
auf dem basar im nachbardorf nani in
begleitung der taliban reden nur die
dänen die neuen machtverhältnisse
gefallen
wir sind so müde
die straße ist zerstört so gott will
wird uns die taliban-regierung hier
sicherheit bringen wir sind glücklich
mit den taliban
ich bete dass gott ihnen die kontrolle
über das ganze land gibt vor vier
monaten haben wir die gegend noch ganz
anders erlebt da kontrollierten die
taliban einzelne distrikte jetzt
beherrschen sie fast die ganze region
zwei millionen menschen sogar teile der
provinzhauptstadt gasen haben sie
erobert
mitten durch die provinz führt
afghanistans wichtigste
verbindungsstraße von kabul nach kanal
in den süden rund 20.000 fahrzeuge
passieren den highway number one jeden
tag die taliban kontrollieren jetzt wer
hier durchfahren darf
zurück in den eroberten militärcamp um
die kontrolle zu erlangen haben die
taliban die armee stützpunkte
eingenommen
es war gottes hilfe die die taliban
hatten auch wir hatten opfer
diese siege in ghazni und in anderen
provinzen haben uns mehr waffen und
munition eingebracht die wir brauchen
können um weiter zu kämpfen
sie wirken wie eine straßengang doch sie
haben eine strategie in kleinen gruppen
können sie schnell in die dörfer
einsickern und die straßen beherrschen
ein grund für ihren erfolg
das alles haben sie lange vorbereitet
und nun nach dem abzug der
internationalen truppen ist der weg frei
[Musik]
nur drei stunden autofahrt entfernt
kabul in den vierteln im zentrum der
stadt sind die veränderungen der letzten
20 jahre unter westlichem einfluss
sichtbar und vor allem frauen haben
davon profitiert
wir haben uns mit hoch sarah b 2 und
mass um ahmadi verabredet wir begleiten
sie bei ihrem morgendlichen training 20
kilometer durch die stadt
es ist freiheit die sie sich erkämpft
haben auf die sie stolz sind und die sie
sich nie wieder nehmen lassen wollen
doch sie fürchten den zunehmenden
einfluss der taliban
sie denken frauen gehören ins haus aber
nein das werden wir nicht tun und wir
werden die frauen die zu hause sind und
keine rechte haben ermutigen wir wollen
ein vorbild für die mädchen seien die
sport lieben aber keinen mut haben ihn
auszuüben
vielleicht wird man uns bald nicht mehr
erlauben weiter zu fassen es ist
wirklich eine hoffnungsloser moment für
alle mädchen die radfahren oder andere
sportarten machen auf ihrem handy zeigt
hoch sei ihren instagram account wir
sind bei ihr zu hause im wohnzimmer
sie lebt bei ihren eltern bilder vom
frauenteam des afghanischen fahrrad
verbandes inzwischen ist die 23 jährige
kapitän in der mannschaft vor allem in
social media bekommt sie zuspruch und
anerkennung
wie viel für sie auf dem spiel steht
wird mir klar als sie mir zimmer zeigt
wir sorgen uns um afghanistans zukunft
wenn sie die friedensgespräche dazu
nutzen unser land zu übernehmen
bin ich sicher dass sie mädchen nicht
mehr erlauben rauszugehen auch nicht zur
schule
und was bedeutet das für dich
wir wollen nicht zurück wir werden für
unseren frieden und unsere rechte
kämpfen
es ist sehr schwer zu sagen aber wenn
sie unser land übernehmen dann werde ich
es verlassen
wir fliegen nach masar i scharif in den
norden afghanistans
20 jahre war die bundeswehr hier im
einsatz im juni sind die letzten
deutschen soldaten ausgereist wir
erleben eine stadt in angst und im
aufbruch
polizisten kontrollieren rund um die uhr
alle großen straßen untersuchen autos
nach sprengstoff und waffen und überall
autos auf denen familien ihr hab und gut
zusammen geschnürt haben viele auf der
flucht nach kabul
was ist geblieben und was steht noch
bevor
ist masar i scharif die nächste stadt
die die taliban einnehmen eine region
die unter kontrolle der bundeswehr als
eine der sichersten im land galt ist zum
kriegsgebiet geworden die taliban haben
massiv umzingelt und die polizisten auch
sie ausgebildet von deutschen kollegen
erleben ihre erste harte bewährungsprobe
wir haben unsere patrouillen im
vergleich zu früher verstärkt unsere
checkpoints sind rund um die uhr besetzt
polizeichef prüft sie persönlich tag und
nacht
[Musik]
mit den soldaten sind auch viele
diplomaten und entwicklungshelfer
abgezogen
deutschland hat sein konsulat schon seit
langem geschlossen
zurück bleiben die die mit ihnen
gearbeitet haben die meisten ortskräfte
der bundeswehr leben in masar i scharif
wir treffen uns mit nadschibullah sari
er war übersetzer der bundeswehr
weil sich corona auch in afghanistan
rasant verbreitet tragen die maske im
wohnzimmer setzen wir uns nach
afghanischer seite zusammen auf den
boden
schygulla zeigt uns zeugnisse und fotos
von 2010 bis 2011 war er übersetzer im
camp marmal
schon einmal wurde sein antrag auf ein
visum abgelehnt er fürchtet racheakte
der taliban und möchte dass die
deutschen verstehen wie viel angst er
hat die taliban kontrollieren jetzt die
straße von massakern
wir können massa nicht verlassen sogar
in der stadt herum zu laufen ist zu
gefährlich für uns die antaris sind eine
moderne familie
die sechsjährigen und in dreijähriger
bruder es waren lernen englisch online
weil die schulen wegen corona
geschlossen haben
sie sollen eine gute bildung bekommen
dass das alles in afghanistan nicht mehr
möglich sein soll macht sie traurig wie
viele hatten sie an den aufbau ihres
landes geglaubt sie fühlen sich jetzt im
stich gelassen ich kann hier nicht
arbeiten
ich kann nicht in die stadt gehen sie
ich muss das land verlassen
ich möchte dass die deutschen uns an
einen sicheren ort bringen mégane ist
bereit notfalls mit den beiden kindern
alleine zurück zu bleiben
jeder im viertel weiß dass mein mann mit
ausländern gearbeitet hat auch die
taliban haben diese information
ich denke nicht an die anderen
mitglieder unserer familie
denn das leben meines mannes ist in
großer gefahr und er sollte gehen wir
gehen raus in den innenhof zumindest
hier können die kinder sich frei bewegen
auf die straße sollen sie nicht
die bulle hat die hoffnung noch nicht
aufgegeben 700 ortskräfte so hat er
gehört können mit ihren familien nach
deutschland vielleicht ist jetzt seine
letzte chance doch an wen sollen sie
sich wenden fragen sie uns ich
verabschiede mich mit einem gefühl der
bedrückung wie bei vielen begegnungen
frage ich mich welche verantwortung
haben wir deutschen nach 20 jahren auch
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass
der norden gefährlicher geworden ist
neben kamera und stativ packen wir helme
und schusssichere westen ein
in unserem hotel warten zwei voll
gepanzerte wagen dirk drewes der
projektleiter der entwicklungshilfebank
kfw in masar i scharif holt uns ab
bevor wir los fahren müssen wir durch
die sicherheitsschleuse des hotels
nato-draht spreng wende
überwachungskameras die wörter bewaffnet
kämpfen wir mal das feldlager der
bundeswehr liegt direkt nebenan
hier weht jetzt die afghanische flagge
dirk tewes würde gerne in afghanistan
bleiben auf die veränderte
sicherheitslage muss er sich einstellen
kriminalität dazu genommen in der stadt
ohne zweifel das liegt daran dass sie
die polizeiorgane und sicherheitsorgane
schwächer geworden sind von taliban ist
in der stadt noch nichts zu merken gut
es gibt den einen oder anderen kleineren
anschlag das sind manchmal nur kleinere
bomben auf dem fahrrad befestigt einfach
auch um zu zeigen wir können es ihr
könnt uns nicht daran hindern wir sind
da
wir fahren raus vor uns liegt die
bergkette des hindukusch dirk triebes
kennt sich hier gut aus seit 2011 ist er
schon in afghanistan
sein auftrag das stromnetz im norden
auszubauen bevor es in die
abgeschiedenen bergdörfer geht müssen
wir auch hier einen kontroll posten
passieren
die straße gab es vor zehn jahren noch
nicht jahrhunderte lang konnte man die
bergdörfer nur auf eseln erreichen
wir machen kurz halt um uns anzuschauen
was dirk tewes sein herzensprojekt in
afghanistan nennt 37 kilometer
strommasten quer durch den hindukusch
gebaut mit rund 2,5 millionen euro
deutschen steuergeldern
nach eineinhalb stunden fahrt durch die
berge erreichen wir mal ein dorf das vom
strom profitiert
auch hier fürchten sie die taliban sie
sehen sie als ihre feinde unterstützt
vom nachbarland pakistan afghanistan
abseits der metropolen mit frauen können
wir nicht reden
und die jungen die gerade aus der
koranschule kommen erzählen uns sie
möchten muller werden
fühlen sie sich jetzt im stich gelassen
einer der dorfältesten erklärt mir was
alle hier denken
mit dem abzug der ausländer verdoppeln
sich unsere probleme die ausländer
hatten drohnen und den feind anzugreifen
es ist offensichtlich dass pakistan
unser land angreift ihre generäle kommen
in den norden und töten unschuldige
menschen es geht darum das afghanische
volk zu zerstören der abzug ist nicht zu
unserem vorteil
dirk drees führt mich durch das dorf mit
dem er sich verbunden fühlt aber wir
müssen zurück die taliban rücken auch
hier näher
sie haben gerade die nachbarprovinz
erobert für drewes wird es seien
vorläufig letzter besuch seien die kfw
hat ihren mann nur drei tage nach
unserem treffen
aus sicherheitsgründen nach deutschland
zurückbeordert
was bleibt nach 20 jahren milliarden
dollar militär und entwicklungshilfe in
kaum ein land hat die westliche welt je
mehr geld investiert und doch ist
afghanistan heute eines der
gefährlichsten und ärmsten länder der
welt zurück in kabul fahren wir durch
die sogenannte green sohn das am besten
gesicherte viertel des landes durch
einige straßen kann man nur mit
sonderausweis fahren filmen können wir
nur aus dem auto hinter dicken mauern
und stacheldraht botschaften
regierungsgebäude und afghanistans
größter privater fernsehsender tolo news
im schnittraum sitzt hat sie bat pall 25
jahre alt reporterin
gerade ist sie aus kandahar zurück sie
hat die afghanische armee bei kämpfen
mit den taliban begleitet aufnahmen im
feld im hintergrund bedrohlicher
gefechtslärm obwohl ein journalist
natürlich unabhängig sein muss mit den
truppen unterwegs zu sein gibt der
hoffnung dass wir eine gute zukunft vor
uns haben
das ist welche gibt die die rechte der
afghanen und afghanistans als ganzes
schützen würden ich war da und habe
verstanden was sie auf ihren schultern
tragen wie groß ihre verantwortung ist
für ihren mut ernte die journalistin
viel anerkennung die aufnahmen zeigen
aber auch eine traurige reporterin und
ich denke mir wie schwer es sein muss
wenn das kriegsgebiet das eigene
heimatland ist
wahrscheinlich gibt es eine menge leute
die afghanistan schon verlassen haben
oder die einen ausländischen pass haben
für den fall dass die situation
schlimmer wird dann werden sie sofort
weglaufen
nein als journalistin sehe ich es als
meine pflicht mit meinem volk zu bleiben
die öffentlichkeit braucht mehr denn je
medien die darüber informieren was
passiert
und wahrscheinlich ist es das einzige
womit ich meinem verdienen kann
wie gefährlich ihre arbeit auch in kabul
ist wird mir klar als hassiba ihre
sachen für dreharbeiten in der stadt
packt sieben ihrer kollegen wurden von
den taliban mit einer autobombe getötet
jetzt fahren sie nie ohne helme und
schusssichere westen war irgendwo nach
china wo menschen herumlaufen aber nicht
so überfüllt dass sie bahr will einen
kommentar zur aktuellen lage in die
kamera sprechen deshalb fahren sie in
einem ruhigeren teil der stadt
die reporterin checkt die neuesten
meldungen die taliban sind überall auf
dem vormarsch sie kontrollieren
inzwischen mehr gebiete als die
regierung
[Musik]
es muss schnell gehen
wie halten sie sich lange an einem ort
auf vermeiden ist zu viel aufmerksamkeit
zu erregen auf einen betonträger auf
einem hügel haben sie einen guten
überblick das risiko hier angegriffen zu
werden ist gering
ruhig spricht die reporterin in die
kamera der wunsch nach einheit unter den
menschen wächst seitdem die gewalt
überall im land zunimmt und alleine in
den letzten zwei monaten mehr als 90
distrikte unter die kontrolle der
taliban geraten sind
bartholomäus kabul
so routiniert die 25-jährige auch wirkt
mir wird klar wie tief sich die gefahr
in ihren alltag gefressen hat wenn ein
auto uns überholt dann habe ich sorge es
könnte eine bombe an den wagen
angebracht sein
und sogar wenn ein radfahrer oder jemand
anderes uns zu genau anschaut habe ich
sorge dass er mich erkennen könnte
endlich angreifen könnte all das sind
dinge vor denen sich ein journalist in
afghanistan heute fürchtet 23
journalistinnen und journalisten wurden
alleine in diesem jahr in afghanistan
getötet für die taliban sind
reporterinnen wie hassiba feinde wird
die furcht ihre zukunft sein
ein ganzes land ringt um seine zukunft
und über vielen gräbern lastet die frage
war es das wert so viele tote so viele
jahre krieg wird afghanistan nach dem
abzug der internationalen truppen wieder
einen bürgerkrieg erleben und am ende
die taliban die macht gewaltsam erobern
in kabul military training center dem
größten militärischen ausbildungslager
der afghanischen armee treffen wir die
männer auf denen jetzt die hoffnung
liegt seitdem afghanistans präsident
ashraf ghani zur nationalen offensive
gegen die taliban aufgerufen hat
bereitet damit an dass die rekruten
darauf vor gegen die aufständischen in
den krieg zu ziehen dass sie das in
zukunft ohne internationale
unterstützung tun müssen hat vieles
verändert darauf müssen sich jetzt alle
einstellen
niemand außer uns kann unser land
aufbauen
das ist unser land wir sind die söhne
dieser erde
millionen haben ihr blut gegeben und ihr
leben für die freiheit dieses landes
gegeben weil wir es diesem land schuldig
sind
die männer stehen erst am anfang
sie sind seit 28 tagen hier die
ausbildung dauert insgesamt drei monate
die jüngsten sind 18 jahre alt das
riesige militärgelände 15 kilometer
außerhalb von kabul haben die amerikaner
ausgebaut auch die sowjetische armee war
in den 80er jahren schon hier 40 jahre
krieg auch daran erinnert das
militärgelände
nun ist afghanistans armee auf sich
alleine gestellt
der ausbilder erklärt seinen rekruten
wie sie ihre maschinengewehre
auseinandernehmen und reinigen sollen
amerikanische waffen
ob sie sich darüber im klaren sind dass
sie in zwei monaten wenn die ausbildung
beendet ist vielleicht in einen
bürgerkrieg geschickt werden
abu saabel genau dass er hat sogar seine
stelle im geschäft seines vaters
aufgegeben der 23 jährige kommt aus
einer hazara familie eine schiitische
minderheit in afghanistan
die von den taliban bekämpft wird ich
hatte einen job aber der wunsch meinem
land zu dienen hat mich dazu gebracht in
die armee einzutreten
ich werde dafür eingesetzt für die
befreiung der gebiete zu kämpfen
umgerechnet 160 euro ist ihr sollt weil
er oft nicht ausgezahlt wird gilt die
moral vor allem bei den einfachen
soldaten als schlecht viele der satiren
laufen sogar zu den taliban über die
spitze der armee gilt als professionell
gaga mohammadi wurde von den us-militärs
trainiert durch die bedrohung sagt er
verändere sich alles wir verteidigen
unser land und unsere ehre mit hoher
moral und gutem geist
wir haben eine hohe moral
ich bin darauf sehr stolz das ist ein
gutes gefühl eine kurze mittagspause
mitten im feld auch dass eine
vorbereitung auf das was vor ihnen liegt
sie alle kennen die videos von taliban
die soldaten hinrichten
aber das scheint sie anzuspornen die
schießübungen sind erst der anfang
später sollen sie noch lernen dienen zu
entschärfen verletzte kameraden zu
versorgen und mit dem druck zurecht zu
kommen
denn auf der ami ruhen jetzt die
hoffnungen aller afghanen die für ein
weltoffenes modernes land eintreten
wir sind noch einmal verabredet mit hoch
sei
mit ihrem team trainiert sie am
freitagmorgen am stadtrand von kabul
man merkt es ihnen nicht an aber es ist
heiß staubig und steil und trotzdem
ziehen sie ruhig und gleichmäßig vorbei
hoch saß rat ist eigentlich zu klein
sie hat es gebraucht gekauft andere
haben sich ihr rad geliehen
die trainingsstrecke außerhalb kabuls
können sie nicht mehr nehmen
es ist zu gefährlich immer wieder gibt
es entführungen und anschläge und so
bleibt nur die straße am stadtrand
was für eine nervenstärke diese frauen
haben einigen männern scheint das gar
nicht zu gefallen
doch die polizei bleibt an diesem morgen
immer bei dem team um sie vor möglichen
angriffen zu beschützen
ramin heidari ihr trainer sorgt dafür
dass niemand die mädchen belästigt oder
angreift ein man muss immer dabei sein
wenn sie trainieren
es ist besser als frühjahr da wurden
mädchen oft sexuell belästigt nun können
sie raus die situation ist besser
geworden aber das generelle thema ist
die sicherheit deshalb schirm wie
manchmal die mädchen ab damit sie nicht
um gottes willen ihr leben verlieren
sie machen eine pause der trainer hat
wasser für alle mitgebracht die
straßenkinder die am aussichtspunkt
betteln sind neugierig geworden
es sind die kinder für die hoch sei ein
vorbild sein will
wir machen das unmögliche
ich bin wirklich stolz offen wenn wir
außerhalb der stadt fahrrad fahren oder
in kabul
das ist sehr schwer die belästigen kunst
bewerfen uns mit steinen oder was immer
sie in der hand haben ich werde nie
aufgeben ich werde meine ziele verfolgen
und das ziel hat sie zumindest erreicht
ihr team ist weit über die grenzen
afghanistans hinaus bekannt nicht vor
rekordzeiten aber für den mut mit dem
sie für ihre freiheit und
gleichberechtigung eintreten 2016 wurden
sie für den alternativen
friedensnobelpreis nominiert all das
erleben wir in diesen tagen in
afghanistan
gläubige die in den moscheen für frieden
beten konferenzen bei den frauen in
kabul über lösungen debattieren die auch
ihre rechte einschließen und abseits der
hauptstadt dorfälteste in den
bergdörfern des hindukusch die ihre
traditionen bewahren wollen aber die
taliban ablehnen
auch die taliban stehen vor der
entscheidung krieg oder
friedensverhandlungen werden die
hardliner sich durchsetzen
szenen aus einem land am wendepunkt das
ringen um die frage welches land wird
afghanistan künftig sein ist noch nicht
entschieden